[Music]
let's go north of the border toronto
canada dylan joins us there dylan how
can we help
hi i uh
so i have just over a quarter million
dollars of consumer debt on top of two
houses that i own whoa um a rental in my
primary residence um
and
thousand dollars of
consumer debt
yes yeah and then what is it what is
that debt how did you get it
um so i bought a i bought a property um
and then the renovations cost 150 000
just over um
and then
taxes um that i haven't paid for my my
business um that
are fifty thousand dollars and then the
rest just sort of
things here and there so the two houses
you mentioned they're a part of this 250
000.
no no the house the rehab on one of the
houses
okay exactly all right so let me ask you
a follow-up here so uh uh
is one of the houses paid off what's the
debt on the house is if any
yeah so the one i owe uh or i own sorry
50 50 um with my dad and that one
we owe
well i my portion is 277 000 and then
the other one is 670 000. that i owe
so you're a million dollars in hawk
yeah yeah i want to make sure we're
dealing with yeah you're not
dollars a million 250
in the whole you're a million plus in
the whole leveraged out all right so
what's your question
so my question is um obviously i'm gonna
be selling my um everything property
everything good
so then what
um i'm wondering with the debt snowball
should i pay off um
because my i have smaller debts on line
of credits should i pay them off first
because they're smaller or my parents
who i owe 100 000 each do the debt
snowball parents the debt to the parents
is is in the snowball yeah who cares the
one the one caveat here is you said you
owed fifty thousand dollars and i'm
ignorant here in the uss irs what is it
in canada
the cra but yeah i figured that one goes
first yeah the the one you want to roll
out that's the only time we get out of
the baby steps is if you're in hawk to
the government because you're going to
take everything else from you too how
much is the house worth the rental the
one you owe 600 000 on
uh the rental is worth 800 000 the
market's been uh kind to us that way
okay um
and then sell it today sell it this
afternoon tell your dad we're selling
this house
will he do it that's the plan
uh i think so yeah because he's incurred
some debt in our uh recent renovations
how much is the other house
the other house is um
probably worth about 900.
um what do you owe on that one 6.75
are you married
uh i have a partner yeah okay do you
have uh kids
no okay how old are you
i'm 26. okay
if i'm you let me back it up if you're
my son or you're my best friend and you
come to me and you're 26 and you tell me
what you're telling me i would tell you
to sell
your primary residence your
million-dollar residence i would tell
you to get with your dad and sell that
thing
get squared up with the government
get squared up with all of your debts
have zero have some cash you'll end up
with some cash here if you do this right
and either buy a small home that you can
actually afford based on the income you
produce from your business by the way
which is a business that pays taxes from
now on or rent for a year or two and
just get your bearings back you're man
you are underwater you know that though
right
100 yeah are you just stressed out of
your mind yeah
i don't know how you breathe absolutely
okay then john's right i i couldn't
agree more i would have said the same
thing because of the not just the
financial freedom but can i just throw
the emotional freedom in this i mean
dude which they're they're obviously
tied together
but this isn't just a numbers play right
this is some health and your future and
and uh if you can fund that emergency
fund and then save up for a little bit
while and rent and then you guys buy
again i mean hey that that's the play
yeah dude your your relationship with
your dad gets better relationship with
the partners relationships everywhere
get better do you be able to breathe
what business do you
have uh funnily enough i'm a realtor
well then here's the other thing you
know you know that you can make up
ground quickly
yeah yeah hey dude
i i don't even think this is even up for
vote no i mean well at the end of the
day you're voting john and i are
consulting i would sell everything hey
we're talking fresh start imagine how
that would feel january 1st 2022 you
could be out of a million dollars in
debt have a new smaller place you can
take care of and you will be able to
sleep the whole night without popping
awake at 3am how does that sound
it sounds
much better
yes yes yes yes so do it dude yes do it
yes do it do it do it do it man can it
gets it
you just look at the the instagram or
you look at the computer you look at
whatever's on tv and you just think oh
that's the path yeah and i can just
borrow my way too
and man what a blessing we talk to
people who are 60 having this
oh crap moment in the middle of the
night he's 26 man he's got his whole
life ahead of him oh hey we're talking
about being a multi-millionaire as a
result of this too absolutely doing it
the right way and being able to be a
multi-millionaire and breathe at the
same time yeah yeah and i love it's got
the income potential with being a
realtor uh i'd be going bananas because
you could fast forward all everything i
love it